it's a funny thing about pricing
sometimes it has no relation to how much
attention you get in a car for instance
take the 2015 Lamborghini Huracan its
track ruddy with a 610 horsepower v10
engine Lambos unmistakable styling and
an unforgettable roar
in this raging Bowl you'll never have to
honk or shout to announce your presence
the car does all that for you credit
those ribcage like rear vents the
perfect arc of its back stretched taut
over the road and the exposed engine
cavity the hurricane will hit 60 miles
per hour in 2.9 seconds and reach a top
speed of more than 200 miles per hour
the steering is sharp and attentive even
around corners and I was most impressed
by the perfect perfect brakes you
realize how important they are when
you're on a racetrack because you break
very hard very abruptly and the brakes
are amazing
they're in stettin
now about that price tag the 2015
hurricane has a base price of under 240
thousand dollars that's two hundred
thousand dollars less than other
Lamborghinis like the Aventador sure you
can take it on the track and we did but
it'll actually feel more at home on the
highway than any other Lamborghini to
date inside the electric heated sport
seats offer more comfort than just a
track mule and the contrast stitching
and futuristic dashboard integrate well
into daily normal life out of any
Lamborghini this is the one that is not
for a track of course you can take it on
the track but this is the one that
you're going to drive every day and take
to work or two
you know parties out for the night
whatever
which is not to say this car is
practical by any means it's not the
front position trunk is so tiny it'll
hold only one small shoulder bag the
clearance is so low you'll be sweating
speed bumps it gets only 14 miles per
gallon in city driving and the
visibility is terrible if all of this
sounds like a mixed bag that's because
it is but the Huracan is the company's
most versatile car to date and if you
have your heart set on a Lamborghini
this could be your best bet